Chaos represented as well. That stack
deck
>> and uh cold shot package doing a lot of
work alongside the final flights. We saw
how powerful those could be in the
dazzling Aurora coming out from SebieQ.
What a performance all around. What a
day it has been. And we still have one
best of three to round it all out.
>> I'm so excited. I'm sure the players are
shaking with anticipation as they all
set up. The crowd is going wild here.
>> And it is. I believe we are getting
ready for the finals. I heard that we
are ready. So, let's go. Let's get to it
in just a moment. We're going to switch
over to the other cast pair. I believe
break is ready is what was said to me
and I was kind of I was kind of throwing
to the break at that time. We're getting
ready for the finals. We're going to go
and get ready and we'll switch over to
the other casters. So, let's do that.
Let's go. One more series.
[music]
Hallelujah.
Heat. Heat.
[music]
Welcome back everybody. Everybody, I am
extremely excited to say we are about to
go to the finals here in Bolognia. James
Olirri joined by Leonard Koig for the
final best of three today. And no matter
who wins, the winner will be Polish.
Yes, absolutely. The crowd has been
going ballistic all the time. They
really do love it. So many talented
players from Poland have made their way
over here. So, it's not really the
biggest surprise that we have a full
Polish final. Something that else won't
be much of a surprise to all of you at
home is that we need a moment. The
players need a moment just to settle. I
mean, Sebie literally just got thrown up
in the air. Uh, the entire Polish
community kind of rallying around. Even
Allan was in there throwing Sebie up. I
was like, "Hang on a second. You're
about to you're about to face off." Um,
so we do have a few minutes just to talk
about through the progression of the
tournament. Um, and I would say a lot
has been learned about Spirit Forge
today, uh, and yesterday as well. A lot
of a lot of hype coming in with the
Spirit Forge changes with Draven coming
into the meta. Everybody said there this
is a tier zero format in that people
were saying Draven is above and beyond
the best champion to play. Um I think we
at least have seen that yes it's
consistent but it is not dominant in the
way that it will just crush through
everything in a tournament because no
Dravens made the top four. It had the
best conversion rate from day one to day
two,
>> which is impressive. I never want to
discount that. But we look at the top
eight.
>> Yeah. And all of a sudden, top eight
still the most played deck is Draven.
But then in those semi-finals, the top
four, no Draven anymore. This is not the
League of Draven. This is more the
League of Ezreal or is it Misfortune?
Yeah, it's it's a weird one cuz we find
ourselves in a situation where I'm like,
well, you can't say that Draven's not a
great deck, but at the same time, like
in these very high pressure matches, in
these kind of very unique setups, like
when we look at top eight, it was
Dravens, it was an Aurelia, a Victor, a
Misfortune, an Ezreal. All of those are
extremely different play styles. Every
single one is very unique. And it feels
like perhaps while Draven was consistent
and was able to outdraw a few matchups,
maybe not having the specific targets
like ways to play against everything in
a in a hypersp specific matchup. Maybe
that is one of the weaknesses. I'm going
to have to review the footage myself and
and I'm sure everyone will talk about it
for a long time. But needless to say,
being in this position, I was not
expecting it to be Ezreal and Misfortune
being the uh the decks in our finals.
>> Absolutely. I mean, and Ezreal, I could
have said yes before the event because
Lenzq has been very bold about his
Ezreal plays for the next few
tournaments. He even said that he's
going to win multiple metal cards. That
is already a good start to this being in
the finals. However, Misfortune might be
a tall hill to climb for him because the
Aurora match up could be difficult. But
all of those four decks in the top four,
>> they have one specific goal and that is
beating Draven. All of these decks are
built to beat Draven. The thing is the
Draven decks, they are also built to
beat other Draven. [laughter] And then
if you are in this scenario where you're
not playing versus Draven anymore, you
go draw the short end of the stick.
>> Yeah, we we have a few more moments
before we actually get into our finals
where we will dive deep into Ezreal and
Misfortune. Um I feel like Aurelia had
good placements. Um we obviously saw
Crows a couple of times on the stream
playing that. I think it it did a lot of
work off stream uh at at the table area
playing against a lot of Kaisers. Uh did
a good amount of work in the matchups
that people were successful with it. Um
likewise, I think Victor kind of flew
under the radar for a little while. We
at the beginning of Spirit Forged had
the Plano units Victor all kill spells.
Then we had the Vanguard Armory. Are you
trying to cheat out Jace? You know Jace
cheating out Vanguard Armory? Can you
make that work? And didn't really have
the success that people were expecting.
There's now this aggro victor with the
Zinhow. A little bit of a mix kind of
lots of kill spells does have the
ability to go wide. So, [music] I'm
excited to see obviously we have Las
Vegas regionals next weekend. I'm
excited to see where things go with the
meta over in North America. Yeah, I
really like especially this Victor deck
because it is [music] an aggro deck. You
know, you're trying to rush, especially
against some slower decks, but with very
little cards you're playing. You can
keep your kill spells in your hand while
you just go token token and then play a
Zen Xiaou. So on your first turn where
you basically can move your units that
are ready, you have a token and a jouo
to already conquer and you get two
points by just playing one card in two
turns. And that is I think not only very
valuable but that's also super fast just
by abusing this leader ability. I love
the play style of the deck.
>> Very efficient like oh I basically have
to spend nothing to get to to this
point. So does accelerate the game and
of course was there in the semifinals
match losing to Sebi but it was a hard
for match hard for match I I genuinely
as we were looking back and forth I was
like oh if this wasn't Aspirin's climb
there was a real shot for getting over
to eight points but that ninth point
just one extra one against all of the
mine spplitters the volley bears
everything just too much to get through
and I I think [music] there was that
clutch like Imperial decree uh not a
factor in that matchup anymore after it
got removed.
>> Actually crazy. I mean, it's already
really tough to play versus this deck if
you're curving mobilize into catalyst of
aons into the dazzling Aurora. But then,
of course, we've been saying this so
many times when talking about Aurora.
You're trying to play more mind
spplitter than everything else just so
you can find that mindsplitter
immediately, get rid of the gear hate,
and then in the next turn afterwards,
there was another mind spplitter being
played from hand. Get rid of the
vengeance. And then in the endst step,
Aurora got another the third mind
spplitter to get rid of the Imperial
decree.
>> Yeah, that sequence
>> so bigoo that that sequence it's uh
those moments where it's right down to
it. It's it's just the order of the
cards, how it comes out, the way we've
seen Sebie be uh you know blessed in the
[music] way that the catalyst and
mobilize combo has come off a couple of
times today to to beat the mind
spplitter, to beat the way uh of getting
some of the gear removal. So, we'll see
how that goes in a final against Allen,
which is coming up very shortly. Again,
the players are getting settled, getting
themselves onto our featured match area.
Uh, it is a grand finals, so we don't
want to rush them to to to get
themselves together. Of course, both
very experienced players. I mean, we've
talked about Allan being best of Kaiser
from Houston, the best of Ezreal here
today. Naturally, that means Sebie is
the best of Misfortune. But we do have
the meta breakdown here and I think it's
interesting looking at day one's results
into day two. This of course we saw some
civ. That's what we're expecting to see
Aurora run on, but it's the misfortune
in the finals. And also very surprising
actually is the complete abundance of
Kaiser in top eight. There was no
Kaiser. I thought at some point this
deck might be the best deck in the
tournament, but there's so many other
deck that can try to beat it. And
apparently that happened quite a lot.
But I mean, we have seen a decent
conversion rate of Aurelia as well,
which is the arc nemesis of Kaiser,
right? It's just like in League, right?
If the Fed Aurelia comes your way and
you're an AD carry, there's not really
>> Oh, yeah. You get one shot at that
point. Uh you you just cry
those days of of being a backline
champion, although Kaisa always was a
little bit more front line at times. Um
Aurelia definitely deals with the
squishies like that in League of Legends
and also um in Riftbound as well. I've
been told that we do have a little bit
of time still before we get into our
finals. Um, Ezreal, a deck that has had
many iterations already in in uh, Spirit
Forge. We
>> heard a lot about the rat Ezreal, which
was pit crew plus call and you just kind
of like do the loop of the battlefields
and untap, untap, untap. And
>> people thought, okay, maybe this is a
way to play against Raven. Then it fell
off because people realized if the if
the pit crew dies suddenly the strategy
is is not so good if you can't move to
the battlefield.
>> Then we saw the move um to kind of a lot
closer to what Allan's playing today. I
would say there was also the pack of
wonders strove iteration of the deck
that was also quite strong. So you could
just basically uh
>> you would ramp.
>> We saw that a little more recently
actually. That's that's a weird one
where where I I felt like that might be
something that we'd see come in in the
site cuz there was like online
tournaments over the last couple of
weeks and we saw one do quite well with
the the pack of wonders and I was like
is this the tech? Is it the pack of
wonders? Keep playing the mind
spplitters. Keep playing the mind
spplitters. Uh turns out not for this
tournament. Maybe maybe we'll see it in
future. Maybe this deck that uh that
Allan has put together with the rest of
the team. I know a lot of the the crew
from Turnum Sideways have been putting
together uh some some practice sessions
at least. I I was speaking to Kasanova
and and the team earlier saying, "Yeah,
I've been playing against this Ezreal
deck for like weeks weeks and weeks and
weeks and it it's uh it's a a tough one
to play against." So, shout out to the
entire crew there working with Allan to
uh seemingly look at breaking the meta
from a a Draven
focused meta to now, hey, there's a
whole lot more to play.
>> Agreed. I mean, again, those decks are
also meant to beat Draven. If you're
playing a deck [music] that is beating
Draven,
>> I think your Aurora matchup becomes
significantly harder because what are
you doing with all of your light
removal? You have these big tempo turns
with your thousand tailed Watcher and
then you have double frigid touch,
bellows breath, stuff like that. But if
there's double volley bear imposing,
what are you removing with this? That's
a really good question and we'll come
back to that because I want to talk
about how ineffective the gear removal
will be from the Ezreal matchup. That's
something we'll pick up back in game.
So, put a pin in that point for now as
we look at the day 2 conversion rates or
at least the the share of the meta
coming into our final five rounds of
Swiss and then the top eight. So, as we
were talking about, Draven was
successful. Yeah,
>> it is it is no way to understate how
many Dravens made it through. I think it
was just shy of 40% of Dravens converted
to day two when the math was all done.
>> 38% of Dravens.
>> Yes, exactly. Just under 40% that 38,
the share of the top uh players in day
two, at least the players in day two was
34%. Both of those numbers are
impressive for any deck to to get
through as a percentage of the field. So
realistically, it is a solid choice. I
think we may see iterations now on these
deck lists of like how do we play into
some of these more unorthodox matches
where we can't just be Mr. Consistent.
>> Yes. And then all of a sudden when
you're trying to focus on other
matchups, I think this is where Draven
starts to shine again because you cannot
simply disrespect this deck when you're
building your own when you're preparing
for example the regional qualifier in
Leo or Vegas if you're preparing for
these events. Draven, I mean just look
at the pure meta share, right?
>> There's so many of them, especially in
day two, even if we do not [music] have
any in top four.
>> Yeah. all of these decks just had to go
through so many Draven.
>> I think the elephant in the room is
chaos uh in that
>> when you look at the the percentage of
champions coming through, I think it's
hard to ignore
>> uh not something that we should ignore.
Talking about the strength of a lot of
the cards in Chaos right now, there's
versatility all the way down. You need
uh mo like spells that will push things
away. Yeah, you got that. Rebuke will
put things back to to hand. You'll you
have card draw. You have solutions to
many many things including combat tricks
now with switcheroo that are can just
kind of blow through a big unit there.
It's not only a strong combat trick but
also you have flexibility in playing it.
You can bluff it with other cards as
well. It's incredibly strong and I think
honestly
>> the best card in the game might just be
fight or flight.
>> It's hard to play around for sure. It's
you always have to be thinking about it,
right? And that's the thing is I think
chaos by name, chaos by nature in that
all of the cards being very efficient,
quite cheap, high impact cards um that
no matter whether you're running it with
body [music]
uh or you know any of the meta decks
that we've seen today and the non-meta
decks, regardless of what you're
playing, you're able to just get through
like Red Purple is such such [music] an
intense combination that the multiple
decks there Jinx the Draven as
I mean that was this different iteration
of the Draven deck that we haven't
[music] seen in top eight. I think there
was a miracle Draven right where you
were playing with battering [music] ram.
You were playing the seals of discord
trying to play so many cards in one turn
with rases. This is how so many Jinx
players also got into day two, right? We
have eight day twos. Before that, Jinx
was not really a factor in these
tournaments. But you would just say,
"Okay, I do not have the Draven legend
ability, but maybe I want to go for the
best of metal card. I'm just going to
play a basically Draven deck list
without the Draven leader and that was
the Miracle Jinx iteration.
>> Yeah, unfortunately we did get to see
Ry's game. I believe that was the list
that Randy was playing did fall in the
top eight to the Aurelia uh matchup that
you mentioned best of cards. I think
that is one of the amazing unique things
that we get to bring you in these
regional qualifiers in Riftbound. We get
to not only crown a champion, we get to
crown a champion of each legend. Uh, and
that is something that we've enjoyed
tracking the entire event. We of course
with our top eight have individuals that
have determined that for themselves
already this finals. We know it's not a
mirror matchup. So, it is the best of
Civ, the best of misfortune. Sorry,
Ezreal. See, I keep thinking it's Civ
Aurora, but it's not. It's Misfortune.
Ezreal and Misfortune. Um, and there
were 28 legends and 28 best off cards
I'm pretty sure have been given out. I'm
pretty sure we had every champion uh
represented if I remember the the
graphic we saw yesterday. So that is a
lot of players having that you know very
special momento of their time here in B.
>> Absolutely. It's such a cool card with
we have actually just seen some
backstage of course and they are
phenomenal. Would really like to have
one of the if you were going to a
tournament to chase a best off card
which one would it be? Well, you know, I
I would say it was the what I predicted
for for this event, but that means I'd
be playing Draven along with everybody
else that played Draven. That is a
crowded field because I did predict that
Draven would do really well. Um,
>> and I'll kind of take half of a win cuz
it's not going to win the tournament. In
fact, none of us are going to take a win
on this. Uh the closest ironically is
>> probably medic if I'm being honest
because the civ deck is kind of this the
the the similar archetype but none of us
were right.
>> I mean Fiora is close to Ezreal in play
style, right?
>> Somewhat.
>> Says who?
>> Okay. Nobody actually says who. But if
you had to go for a a metal best off
card, what what would you play? I mean
I'm I'm sure that you wouldn't go for
Draven, right? Except if you're the
biggest Draven fan in the world, then
you have to try your luck.
>> Yeah, that's a really good question. I I
mean I know I wouldn't get it anyway,
but I think before the event and before
some of the content that we saw from
content creators around Rexi, I was
thinking like maybe Rexi is a good
shout. Uh Darius, I know there was quite
a high level of competition for the the
Darius.
>> Really fell off later on in the
tournament, but it was a high
concentration of very very good standing
Darius at the end of day one.
>> Yeah, there there there's honestly I
someone's going to pull me up on this
when I say this. I don't think that
there was an easy best of no. uh to pick
up because every every single champion
had uh somebody contesting you for it.
So uh I I will very much enjoy looking
at the standings and seeing where did
every best of place uh because we had so
many players here. I mean it was um you
know I think between attendees and uh
competitors I think we were near 3,000
people here in Bolognia across the
weekend which is is crazy. That was
that's not an official stat. That is
just I counted everyone as they came in.
>> I was the Yeah, that's that was my day
one.
>> Well, other people had breaks.
>> Yeah. No, I I just counted. I just made
sure that I kept an eye on everybody
that came in. And uh people that came in
participating. I'm going to start from
the bottom and work up here. People that
came in did get that participation promo
of the Bone Shiver. Super cool art on
that one. The top eight got their part
their promo of uh the Blade of the Ruin
King, but we're determining the
championship prize, the Blade of the
Ruin King alternate art and the playmat
that goes along with it, as well as of
course uh you know the the prizes for
first through 32nd you see at the bottom
of the screen. I'm pretty sure top 64 uh
also by themselves the qualifier through
to regional championships uh which we of
course will be building through and as
mentioned there was the best up pricing
throughout the day as well. So a lot to
play for even if you weren't aiming just
for that top spot. Definitely so many
cool promos, cool prices as well and if
you're getting first $6,000 that's a lot
of booster packs.
>> It is. It is. Uh yeah, that's uh that
would be an enjoyable like hour of just
>> tearing into booster packs. Um
>> that is hour you have to take your time,
you know, you have to worship every
booster packs and you're there for half
a week basically.
>> You look Do you look you looking through
the commons in in every pack? Yeah,
exactly. When people skip right to the
back, I'm like, "No,
>> do it in order. Do it in order. I want
to see the whole pack."
>> Exactly. How many good comments do you
actually pull? And some of these cards
that haven't been paid a lot of
attention to before have actually really
shined in this tournament. Something
like a ruin runner that was not the most
anticipated card from the set has
actually proven to be quite successful.
We've seen some matches. For example, in
day one, the set brawler
>> versus the Kaiser, which is already a
tough matchup for Kaiser. However, as
soon as the rune runner hit the field,
there was almost no out for Kaiser. I
think if you drew the humps of a camel,
you would see the interest in ruin
runner because it was like it got
released and people went, "Ooh, this is
a good card." And then for some reason
everybody just was like, "No, let's not
play that card. Let's not do that." And
then people played Kaiser again and
people realized, "Hang on a second, Ruin
Runner." And we went back up for the the
extra hump on the camel. Um I mean you
you speak about commons, one of the most
impactful um you know lower than rare uh
card in the set. Cold shot is
>> an insane card for efficiency. Uh paired
with an Ezreal, it is uh borderline in
my opinion a little bit broken in that
you just get to see two cards. Oh, I'll
take one of those. I'll see another two
cards. Okay, cool. Didn't really pay for
it. Seal got tapped and that's it. I
really can't wait for an echo legend at
some point because we have multiple
cards already that feature echo on them.
We of course also have one echo that is
usually only played in Renata Glask
strategies to go for a big time warp.
And then we have the big time warp which
has echo on it and of course cold shot.
You're seeing Ekko's back facing
somewhere. So Ekko is uh causing quite
the kuruffle.
>> I'm I'm interested to see what the
mechanic ends up being with Ekko cuz as
so in League of Legends I played a lot
of Ekko. Um, and when you're an echo
player,
>> I I was bad, but I wouldn't say horrible
because as an echo player, at some point
you kind of just always have to be
thinking 4 seconds in the past cuz the
the the uh the the spirit that goes
behind you that you can jump back to.
So, what are we going to jump back at
the end of a turn or something like
that? Instead of a time warp, there's
like a mini time warp. Uh, we have no
insight into what is coming next.
>> Very dimension
>> for Rift. Yeah, extremely important to
say. We have no idea. We're just
speculating on that. Um, and we enjoy
hearing your speculation as well on
everything, whether it's your your
thoughts on the results here at the
tournament or what you think is coming
next to Riftbound. Um, if you are
getting involved in the conversation,
use the # RQ Balonia on social media.
And we will endeavor to read your tweets
at some point and uh and and wherever
you're posting, we'll we'll find it.
Definitely. And now I have another
speculation for you.
>> I'm I'm going to ask you for one.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Aurora versus Ezreal.
>> Okay, let's get in towards the matchup.
No, we're we're getting there.
>> Yeah. What What do you think has the
advantage there? Obviously, Alanzik has
been aura farming so much so far, but
this all of these tiny removalish spells
that he's playing,
>> I don't think they threaten Volibear too
much.
>> Yeah. And and not only threaten
Volibear, I think um to look at it as a
as as a very first step and [music] you
know, we're building our way towards
understanding this matchup because it's
not one that we see very often. [music]
Um, I would say Ezreal has a tendency to
take a few turns of just stack deck, you
know, play smaller units maybe, uh, and
then kind of like try and get the seals
out and you're playing to discard,
playing to set up your your trash in
order to do more on the back end. Um,
Aurora, I I would imagine, takes a look
at that and goes, "Okay, cool. I'll
catalyst. That's fine." Um, aside from
maybe like a hard bargain on a catalyst
turn, I feel like those early
not pressure the Aurora too much. I I'm
willing to be wrong on this. I I would
love to see how this plays out in in in
game. I've had the same feeling about
the matchup. Obviously, I have also not
seen too much of it. We can take a look
at the deck list of our two finalists
right now to see which particular single
cards could help because there's quite a
few one-offs on the side of LNZQ.
>> Yeah, one copy of Hard Bargain. So to
line that up with a catalyst would be,
you know, fortunate to say the least.
Um, stack deck, of course, we talked
about drawing into it.
>> There's not a lot here that I feel like
interacts too much.
>> Agreed.
>> And I think something would have to have
gone wrong for um for Seb's Aurora to be
that late that the mindslitter is that
much of an impact, especially when
there's only one main board. I mean, if
your opponent is at some point
completely exhausted on runes and you
have the thousand tailed Watcher with
Arcane Shift together in the
combination, you can actually reduce
might to six if you can go if you do
have the time for a big turn and then
you do have a repeat Bow's breath. So,
there is a possibility if your opponent
really does not have an answer to any of
that to get rid of the mind spplitters.
>> Yeah,
>> Polybear different story.
>> I'm trying to think about that. Is is
there a way
through the Volibears on a battlefield?
Cuz it's 10 might without being in a
defensive position in a showdown, right?
>> I think maybe we give the deck too
little credit here because we have seen
how many cards if given time the deck
can assemble and then you're already
sitting at at what 10 cards in hand.
Maybe if your opponent doesn't disturb
you at all, you might be sitting at 12
or 13.
>> There are multiple wages of pain frigid
touch as well. You can play Fizz, you
can repeat those cards then maybe even
finding a smoke screen or something. You
also have the rebuke. However, mind
spplitter is going to make that more
difficult.
>> Yeah, looking at it like frigid touch
with thousand watcher. I'm I'm trying to
to do a little bit of the math. That
would be 10, right? Do you have the
repeat cost of availability? I think
actually because of the extra it's one
too many. We we'll get there in the
middle of the game. Um, I think the late
game potentially is there for Allen if
the sequencing of cards like if the
right set of cards to to minus the enemy
units and then go in uh comes through.
But that is quite a lot of like late
game that we have to get to with the
right cards.
>> That is true. But I mean that is also
the strength of the miracle decks,
right? You have so many cards like stack
deck and the cold shot that you can
basically decide whenever your opponent
is starting to pressure you which cards
you do have in hand if your opponent is
not pressuring you already so much. Now,
let's look at the other deck.
I'm quite curious. I mean, we have seen
Sabi just go all in and there is one
card just in the middle of the screen.
That is looking terrifying for LMZQ.
>> Yeah, invert timelines. The important
part is each player discards their hand.
Doesn't matter how much you got in your
hand, it's all going to the trash. Um
then of course you draw more cards on
the back side, but if you've discarded
20 and you're drawing four, not a trade
that you want.
>> Exactly. This is a card that can at any
point really threaten big disruption
against AlanzQ. So he will have to find
either a way of playing around it going,
okay, I will try to establish a bot that
is big enough that I can threaten you if
you drop your Aurora, if you get your
units in. or he is going for an absolute
high roll and says, "You know what? I
know we're friends. I know you're only
paying one invert timelines.
>> You're not having that. You are not
going to find that." Another interesting
thing is as soon as dazzling aurora is
being played, there is a decent chance
with so little units in the deck that
the dazzling aurora immediately reveals
that the invert timeline is not in the
hand of Sebie Q. Right? So that could
give him the information of, hey, if
this card was revealed, it's going to
the bottom of the deck, we can chill for
a moment. We can play around that if you
do not see the card, starting to sweat a
little bit more, maybe change off plans.
Yeah, that uh certainly could turn the
tide of the game. Uh just as a reminder,
we are getting ready for our finals
here, which is why we are taking some
time to just build towards this best of
three between [music] Allen and Sebie.
It's been a a hard fought road for both
of them to get to this point.
>> Definitely. And now my question is, is
it still possible for us to see these
side decks of these players again?
Because
>> I'm going to say no.
>> Okay. All right.
>> We might hope so. I hope so. I'm not in
control of that
>> because I mean we have seen some gear
removal on the side of Alen's EQ in
Pigpocket. This is targeted at all of
those other miracle decks. You know what
Pig Pocket doesn't Yeah. remove.
>> I'm glad we came back to this. It
doesn't remove Aurora because uh it is
limited to what it can do and we'll talk
about that when we get into the game. We
are ready for the first ever finals for
a Riftbound regional qualifier in Europe
live from Bolognia. Let's get going.
Introducing first, undefeated in Swiss,
the best of Ezreal today, the best of
Kaiser from Houston. It is Alan ZQu.
What a player. What a man. The people
are cheering for him. He has played to
perfection. Not only are they cheering
for Alan ZQ, they are cheering for the
best of Misfortune Countryman playing
the deck that everyone counted out from
Origins. It is Sebie Q
ready for a fight. Definitely is going
to put up a hell of a fight against his
friend Alen ZQ. They're shaking at Sevi
as well with a phenomenal performance.
The biggest upset of the tournament is
Misfortune in the grand finals and we
are soon going into our finals match.
The trophy is there. We know what's on
the line. Both of these players the best
of already for their champions. But who
will take home the Blade of the Rune
King promo, the playmat, and the glory
of being not just the best of Ezreal or
the best of Misfortune, but the best of
the best today here in Bolognia.
>> It is a very interesting matchup.
Something that people have not
considered before. Bolognia, both of
those decks. We're actually already
starting to play. We have channeled the
rune. So, I think let's just swap over
to the tables. A stack deck start.
Oh, we've actually had a two drop on the
side of Alen's EQ there. I haven't seen
that in a while.
>> Yeah, we we were raring to go to get
ready into this one. So, stack deck
comes out as well. There is decision
between a challenge and a cold shot.
>> Are we going to find a mobilized Sebie
Q? He is smiling. He is green. Oh, he's
actually passing. So, we are delaying
that ramp a little bit. There's a high
chance now that there's a catalyst of
AON in hand just statistically speaking.
But Alanzq already has a decent shot at
scoring points here with a Raven Bloom
suited. I think for this matchup, it's
incredibly important that you find that
two drop that you actually get to your
points early.
>> Something interesting going to the
bottom of the deck from Alan ZQ,
Singularity. one of the big spells that
can at least set up uh the way through
mine spplitters potentially through
volley bears now not an option for a
very long time in this game after
Allen's EQ earlier was playing a game
where he didn't want to play the seals
out at any point we'll just drop it
early and be like yeah this is good this
match up I don't need to care
>> yeah there is no pickpocket staring at
you the entire time that is a heck of a
start for Alan EQ discards the stupifery
draws two cards instead and finds the
mighty T the one and only mind spplitter
to his hand which could be a card that
if we're not ramping up too fast on the
side of SEQ could take away a dazzling
Aurora from hand before it could be
played. The win condition the one and
only. So start counting. We're at five
runes this time. Catalyst is in hand.
You were correct. So Catalyst will take
you up to seven. Allan, I believe, goes
to five on the next round when we get uh
the table view again. Yeah, Allan will
go up to five. Then Sebby goes to seven.
Allan, I believe,
>> no, Sebie will go to N.
>> It's going to be too late. Exactly. I
was going to say seven now and then it's
next turn is going to untap, awaken the
runes, and go to nine. So, is there
anything Alan can do about this? Finding
the oneoff mind spplitter early in the
game is huge, but you're too late.
Catalyst of Eons is such a strong card.
Just channeling two runes, especially if
there's not a high aggro deck. Now,
Alanzik will have to find some crazy
amount of resources in this turn alone.
What can you even do here? How many
cards can you set up? How many resources
can you get? And I'm sure we have held
already in the void gate with raven
bloom student. I'm sure you are dramping
yourself now with a sigil and you are
just okay playing a vex now too. I think
>> I think Allan's just accepting that.
Yep.
>> Probably getting Aurora next turn. So I
just need to get some points early then
establish a little bit of control around
the units that come from Aurora.
>> Yep. And oh my goodness, these faces
from Sevi just looking at Allen. He is
hovering over it and he wants to see it.
He has it. Dazzling Aurora. Such a
strong card. The ultimate win condition.
The ultimate weapon for Seabq. And now
Alan Q takes it.
>> So confidence. The reveals off the top.
What's it going to be? Where do we go?
Mind spplitter off the top will split
the hand of Alan's EQ. What are we
getting? It's a mindspplitter. It's a
Fizz stack deck. Raven Bloom or a smoke
screen. Smokec screen might be
surprisingly important in this matchup.
Yes, but I do see a world in which
you're actually also taking the stack
deck because none of these cards are
really pushing you. Actually, you're
discarding. So, this deck would come out
with a fizz.
>> Same with a smoke screen. It it's it's
like it's one of those really awkward
choices of
>> if I discard a spell, Fizz gets it.
>> If I get rid of the Fizz, okay, you keep
the spell, but you don't get a unit in
the spell, but at least Fizz kind of
keeps you in a a strange situation on on
things. So,
>> there's always something to say about
like the the line that each player is
going to choose going forward. I mean,
taking away the smoke screen and then
hard plate Fizz that is going to reduce
your might is not going to be the worst.
Also, there's a stupify in the discard.
>> Yeah, I mean Fizz is a really good card
to take away here because it's the most
flexible. Yeah, you're taking the Fizz.
There is going to be stack deck. There
is going to be smoke screen.
>> Weirdly, you're actually taking away
like the options for both a smoke screen
and a stack deck and a stupify. Um it's
it's an odd one where you're not getting
those cards out of the hand, but you're
getting the second attempt where uh they
could potentially draw into it.
>> Just picks up another for swimmingly.
Oh, you can't mind split the top card of
the deck.
>> And that is going to find a stack deck
immediately
>> and we're going to find another Vex a
watch. That is
>> such an important card in this matchup
to stabilize on the back end of it.
We've talked about the arcane shift with
the watcher is that one route out once
this gets to the late game. That is
possibly the area that I can see Allan
being able to play through this is I
just let you play all the units and then
I can deal potentially with the late
game. But I think both of these decks
have just like heavy haymakers to really
take control of a game. But Allen is
already up to five. Yeah, Alan is racing
in this game. We have used the seal of
discot here of course for the Fizz. He's
going to go for the stack deck. Can he
actually hold another one of those
battlefields? Going to six would be
absolutely huge, especially with a
thousand tailed watcher as follow-up in
hand now. He needs to make absolutely
sure that he is not paying any power
cost this turn because every single rune
is going to be pivotal.
>> But at this point, how much do you need
to kind of like I guess bluff is one way
of putting it? You need to leave up like
runes essentially to rebuke.
>> Yeah. Because if if you can threaten
options, that makes Sebby like opt like
decision making quite tricky here
because Sebie is going to want to take
control of this game. You're going to
try and want to move to battlefields and
you always have to be thinking, okay, if
there's a rebuke here, how do I play on
the back end with no units?
>> Sebi taking the decision of going into
the sigil of the storm.
>> Yeah, of course that plays around
Singularity on on Alan's turn. It's a
second aurora
>> and that second aurora is going to make
almost entirely sure that you are going
to hit another mice better spitter until
you unless you get two volars in a row
and I think that a double volar would be
I think maybe even better.
>> I was going to say is volar better
because you don't get as affected by the
watcher cuz you're going to get that
shield off the top as well. It's a mine
spplitter and a volar
>> but mind splitter is going to take care
of that watcher.
>> Oh mind spplitter will you're totally
right that is if you want. I mean, when
you look at the hand, you got to look at
what else is there, but I feel like that
is the prime target, right?
>> Yeah, I think that is the best card that
you could possibly hit. Alan ZQ back
against the wall. Double Aurora.
Absolute massive stack on the sigil of
the storm. It isn't even the battlefield
that you really want to go into. And now
it is the battlefield that you can't go
into. Immediate watcher taken out by
Sebie Q.
>> And we know that main board is one. Main
board is one watcher. So now we're
looking at last rights
>> potentially to bring it back or morbid
return. Yeah, but then again those cards
do really need a setup especially with
the runes that you're having and then
there's going to be more mind splitters
I would assume.
>> So now See Q with being at one is giving
AlenzQ a little bit of time at least.
>> Yes. So I think what you can do as LNZQ,
I mean you can conquer the void gate
with your most desparable unit which
would be the Fizz.
>> Yeah,
>> I would say and then you are at six and
then you can see what's going to happen.
But the thing is this is not a Civiver.
You are never safe from all of those
mine splitters and vol because
Misfortune just enables ganking. This is
such a huge combination. Big units
ganking from battlefield to battlefield.
You basically have control over both
battlefields while only controlling one.
This is big.
>> Yeah. And it it's really important to
note cards that can kind of get you out
of that because if you can gank over to
the other battlefield and then get your
Aurora trigger to follow up on it. Uh
Rebuke is action speed.
>> So it's not like you can let that
trigger go onto the chain and react to
it because that is not how Rebuke works.
So the the reason I bring that up is
just, you know, it's not like you can
let uh Sebie go for it. There is a last
rights in hand. Two hard bargains. A
punch first catalyst probably
>> not where we're going.
>> Shot to to refill the hand.
>> Almost discarded his own Raven Bloom.
>> Yeah, I'll take that. I'll take the
unit.
>> Double heart bargain is I think very
very tough because this is one of the
cards that you would like to get rid of
the most. There's not really too much
you want to call shot for on the side of
SEQ because you're already so set up.
Punch first also does not seem too
relevant. So I think what you want to
get rid of is hard bargain. But there is
two of those. That's they drive a very
hard bargain. But you know, credit to
Allan in a feature match up at this
caliber in a finals counting the runes
just you know to to take into account
every single thing. Okay. How many
repeated hard hard bargains can you you
have? How many uh are you likely to need
to recycle going forward? And you know,
you got to go through the motions. You
have to to account for everything in a
scenario like this.
>> I mean, as of next turn, your opponent
can just pass and go for a double hard
bargain repeated. So, taking out the
punch first and I mean, that's five
might on one of your battlefields. At
some point, you will try to have you
have to try to conquer.
>> Yeah. And that will uh throw a wrench in
the works. Uh if you're going to punch
first, ask questions while punching is
uh what I would say about that as uh
that is three units stacked on the
battlefield. We're still in Allen's turn
resolving the end of Mindsplitter. So we
go to Sebis again. Any units off the top
of what we don't want to see if you're
in Seb's uh camp for supporters for
Allen's side, you probably aren't that
bothered by that. you would would hope
to see a volar go to hand if you're
looking for
>> wow sabotage and disruption sabotage is
such a strong card here. However, as we
said before, if you want to double heart
bargain on the next turn, if you are
just feeling like there might be an
issue, we're getting Allan immediately
picks up the Raven Bloom student and
says, "Yeah, I'm not fighting for that."
>> Yeah, you can you can throw some combat
tricks at that volley bear, but I don't
think it's helping
>> with one rune and a dream. Yeah,
>> although uh yeah, Vex isn't in combat,
so it doesn't reduce uh things.
>> There is a sabotage.
>> That is going to be the end of that
arcane shift.
>> Oh, that's brutal. Because if there were
a way to kind of combo that watcher
eventually, one Arcane Shift is gone.
>> I think you can just leave that hand
face up, right? Because we all
[laughter] know what's going to happen
at the end of the turn. Dazzling Aurora
is going to find us another
>> Volibear and another And that will be
everything from the deck at that point.
There is a mind spplitter likely. Yep.
To go over to the volley and as you said
we get the hand revealed again.
>> I mean at this point it feels like it
doesn't really matter but I think that
frigid touch I mean frigid touch is
another guaranteed draw because you're
playing the Ezreal Legends. So if you're
targeting something twice or if you're
twice targeting rather you're going to
get another draw. Denying that is
absolutely huge.
>> Wow. These battlefields are as stacked
as the decks.
Yep, that is massive. And keep in mind,
you do have seven runes left open. It is
almost impossible to get through this.
Yes, Alen's EQ only needs two more
points to win this game, but this is
very, very far away. Actually, we do
have
>> We'll get it. Tapping the seal with the
Ezreal. Will get the repeat cost
basically for free. Gets to look at four
cards. We'll take two of them.
>> Hard bargain for repeat.
>> Paid for. I I think that's just very
much funny. And then another hot bug.
You're just taking away the entire turn
of your opponent.
>> I said it was free gold shot. That is
the most expensive cold shot we've seen
all tournament.
>> I really like this decision of SEQ
because, [music]
>> you know, he has to AlensQ has to pick
up the pace massively now because
otherwise the game is just going to end
on this game state. You need to find
more cards. You need to build up more
pressure in your own base. And you know,
the pressure is not not going to be kept
up with this if you pay six energy for a
cold shot.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm I'm trying to look at the
situation now of what are the the ways
that Alan can turn up turn the dial up,
turn up the the the speed or at least
the the pressure in this game that Quot
will resolve. A lot of units still in
base. It's a Vex, it's a Fizz, it's an
Ezreal, it's a mindspplitter
for Allan that is still potent. Sebie is
only on three for now. So next turn
we'll go to five. Turn after we'll go to
seven. So Allan does have time. So going
to develop a Raven Bloom Student.
>> And if you can draw into something that
will bring the Watcher back. Maybe draw
also into the Arcane Shift. There's a
world. It's It's not a big line through
these battlefields, but there is a line.
Yeah, I'm I'm trying to figure out how
to math this right because the Raven
Bloom and Student is going to if you get
more call shots, more stack decks,
stupifies is going to get huge. But then
again, there is so much might just from
the Volibear imposing when you're
attacking it and we're going to reveal
the entire deck once.
>> Yeah, we know it's there and then we're
going to see a rare thing in Riftbound,
which is shuffling.
>> I also do really enjoy that we're not
even playing out the Misfortune Captain.
>> It's It's going to stay there. It's uh
for now you just keep your runes up. You
have so many cards in hand. You threaten
everything defensively. And now this
might be one of the pushing turns for
LZQ because he has found a cold shot.
>> So what what do we need to find here? Is
it a way to bring the thousand tail
watcher back uh recur from the
graveyard?
>> I think that would be 15 might that
you're reducing. So
>> which is a lot.
>> Yes. That's basically one volley bear.
[laughter]
>> So a lot. Yes, enough. I don't know
actually because you're also going to
have to play it, right? If you play the
morbid return that is already two energy
gone, so possibly even rather a setup
for the next turn, it is going to be
very, very hard to play through.
>> When you're playing chaos, the best
thing you can do just look at cards.
Look at cards and put them in your hand.
It's all good.
>> They're pretty. They're shiny.
>> You need to try to find answers. The
question is, do you even play answers to
this? Usually with a deck like this with
so much mini removal that you're playing
like wages of pain, frigid touch,
bellowed breath, thousand watcher
combination, you are never this behind
>> was. So I I looked down for a moment.
Was that Bella's breath that went to
hand?
>> Um we'll we'll find out in a moment. Not
exactly the Kaza. Well, I guess retreat
would allow you to watch her again if it
gets there. We know watcher the one copy
in the main deck is in the trash for
now. I'm like would need to do the math
on on how many power and energy you need
in order to watch a arcane shift with a
followup with a Bellow's breath
including a Vex to reduce the cost plus
the repeat cost with Ezreal layered to
get Bellow's breath for free. Is that
enough with a minus 6 plus the Bellow's
breath to get over the mind splitters
and potentially the volat?
>> I think with a minus six we can actually
get there. That's what I'm saying is
like is that line
>> do we play multiple arcane shift copies
because we got the first one discarded
from a mindspp spplitter.
>> I'm going to look I'm going to look at
the deck have it in front. Um
>> it's two copies.
>> All right. Two copies. So there should
theoretically be one more in the deck.
If you find a morbid return you can add
back the watcher.
>> I'm pretty sure that there is no more
hand interruption
>> that you can go for but of course there
are other cards that you can use. There
is also fight of flights or rebukes.
Could you remind me is is the arcane
shift in the trash or did it get put to
the did it get recycled if you remember?
>> I think it was actually it might have
been recycled. I think that we actually
just picked one up with a cult shot and
put it down to the bottom of the deck.
>> So Alan sees a different line. So
looking at the cards in the back of the
hand,
we've got is that double rebuke?
>> That is double rebuke.
>> That deals with the volars and puts them
in a really awkward spot in the hand of
Sebie. You're going to D ramp a lot for
it, but you don't care at this point
because it's just about getting to
eight.
>> Yep. The good thing is as well that you
are playing this somewhere on your turn
on action speed. So,
>> yeah,
>> really nice that your opponent cannot
react with a challenger. I mean, at some
point, your mind splitters are going to
be able to take out almost everything
you do unless your Raven Bloom gets big.
I was going to say if you put the Vex
in, you get the rebukes at reduced cost
because now we're in a combat the Vex is
involved in. So it's actually one and
one recycle to get rid of the Volibear
from the opposing battlefield. We saw
Alan using this to great effect earlier
utilizing the Vex combat showdown status
that is applied to the game to take care
of things away from the Vex for now.
We'll see a follow-up here because there
is a retreat in hand available to kind
of bounce that Vex back after this is
done so that the watcher uh sorry the
the mind spplitter doesn't take care of
the vex. We also have a smoke screen in
hand for Allen. So again reducing the
cost. This Vex is paying off. Both
volars out of the way for Allen in this
first game of the finals. The Raven
Bloom keeps stacking up. There is so
many runes available. But how much
flexibility does the deck of SEQ have? I
mean he is just chilling with all of
those runes. There is punch first but I
also don't think that Lenzq has some way
to return the thousand tailed watcher
this a stupify. There's a smoke screen
in hand. So we know at least there's one
look at the top of the deck for Allan.
Punch first as you mentioned from Sebie.
There is a smoke screen goes onto the
mind spplitter.
>> That would already be enough for the Vex
to conquer. It's now an exceptionally
expensive punch first though because
casting it now is three recycles of
orange runes and they are the only three
here. So pay the price for punch first.
It is an expensive punch. You need to
pick up at least another I say three
orange it's at least uh two orange and
then plus one. So we'll be able to
recycle a chaos. Of course there is no
color um specification on Vex. It is
totally fine to just recycle another,
but it's expensive. Nevertheless,
>> the thing is now with those rebukes,
first of all, you're taking the steam
out of Sebie Q, right? Because
>> you're not holding tube most of the
time, but you also can never play the
Volibear.
>> Exactly. You'll never play the Volibear
now that you've had to invest in the
punch first. And the Volibear being in
hand is the worst place for it to be
when you're playing Aurora because we
know this Aurora will just cycle the
deck. There's a Bellow's breath after
the smoke screen as well. And we know
that there's a stupify in hand. So this
if it's repeated, which I'm sure it is,
there's an Ezreal on the battlefield and
a Vex, which means you layer the
reduction in cost. Vex reduction kicks
in first because there's a to a minimum
of one energy. Then the Ezreal reduction
comes in and basically makes it a free
spell at that point. And you just say,
"Yep, deal the damage. Here comes the
stupify. It's going to take out the mind
spplitter." And on the back end, you've
pumped up this Raven Bloom student. You
have a mind spplitter of your own. Throw
in the Ezreal, throw in the Fizz.
Whichever version of this attack that
Allan decides to do, it's actually a
stupify on the other mind spplitter here
as uh draws another card finds another
stupify. Keep in mind this Raven Bloom
student gets bigger and bigger will in
the end eventually also just straight
away versus one other mind spplitter.
>> Yeah, the damage as uh Stupify is going
to reduce the might as well. or the
damage applied earlier in the turn not
yet represented here. That that student
is has been learning a lot.
>> How is Ellen ZQ?
>> Oh, wages of pain as well. These these
spells are so cheap. The Vex is doing so
much work. Wages of pain on the mind
spplitter that is still in the combat
with the Vex. are still in a combat
showdown and Allen is just taking action
after action after action and now has
control for the seventh point in our
first game of this grand finals. There
surely is enough to take this second
battlefield. Surely Allan turns the
corner from the massively stacked
battlefields that Sebie was able to put
out from double Aurora. Surely this is
it. The wages of pain just kills because
of the void gate. Some extra damage
there is being applied. Max is just
shilling so much. Then in the sigil of
power, there is still two mind
splitters. One might splitter is at five
might. Your own Raven Bloom student is
already at 10.
>> And the thing is Allan's looking at
cards in hand that don't have a whole
lot of utility right now. There's a
retreat.
>> We're now out of the combat showdown
that Vex was in. So no longer is that
cost reduction in play. I haven't seen
Seb's hand in a little while. We know
there's two Volibears in there. So now
it's just down to Allan thinking, okay,
I really don't want for the mine
spplitters to heal. Thank you very much
for putting the damage counter on that
because this will be significant
significant.
>> I think that's the might that it's at
total because the damage has healed up
from the first.
>> Exactly. But it's the stupify that has
been used twice.
>> Sup has been used. You are you are
totally correct. And this is exactly
that moment where Allan is looking at um
the the current board state. So we know
we've got to get past
12. The question is, do you just start
to push in everything or do you start to
poke? Do you have something else? You do
have a lot of runes left open. You could
possibly use a recall on the Ezreal and
try to draw for some more cards. You
could discard that seal of discord that
you have in hand. Try for to find two
more cards that will help you. But are
there any even I mean one recall would
just make your Raven Bloom student
better as well. So what are we going to
do? A Fizz Trickster and the Raven Bloom
is pushing. That should be more than
enough. Might that is 13 versus 12. Is
there an answer from Sebie?
>> The narrowest of margins. Two runes
picked up as Sebby
>> called shot. One, one floating. Three
floating now from the cold shot.
>> He is searching for those reputes. A on
the Raven Bloom student would be
absolutely massive. That would be so
much. There is a gust that might be a
little bit too little too late. But
there is
>> there's a fight or flight.
>> Yes. But is that card enough? That would
just I mean save you from losing the
game this turn for the moment at least.
>> Another cold shot if you need it. Fight
or flight is there will be the the card
used on the Raven Bloom. Raven Bloom
comes back and now becomes a lot less of
a threat. We know that Allan doesn't
have a way of actually getting out of
that situation. Retreat comes through to
save the Fizz.
>> That is going to say we'll go again.
>> Incredible. Because the Fizz can still
play something from your discard pile.
How much damage can you do with it? Can
you just Richie, do you have a frigid
touch in your discard pile that you can
play and repeat? Possibly.
>> We discard
>> already this turn, right? Uh well, we
saw a Bella's breath this turn. Um I'm
pretty sure we have seen a Frigid Touch
go through. Hard for us to keep track of
everything as Allan cycles through his
entire trash. It's Rebuke. Of course,
Rebuke comes out on the mind spplitter
that was at full might. And Allan knows
he's got a mind spplitter of his own to
come towards this battlefield. It's now
just down to what Sebie has in hand.
Still potential outs. We know there's
quite a stacked hand when it comes to
the number of cards in Seby's hand, but
Allan does know a lot of them. He knows
there's a mindspplitter now that he
knows there's two volley bears, but
there's a cold shot. At least we know
there was a cold shot. Drew another card
from the previous end. This time it's a
mindspplitter that goes in.
>> Oh, two more. [laughter] Is there going
to be another cold shot? We're trying to
find for a solution here. Keep in mind,
even if he does find something like a
rebuke, this is going to prolong the
problem. You don't want targets.
>> What do you even want? What is a
solution for everything?
>> There's not a lot of rooms left. I'm
like, you don't even really do much with
that cuz you're not able to trade
evenly. That's only two damage that
comes through. What else is in hand?
>> Then you at least don't lose to the mind
splitter. But there's still a ready to
to conquer behind it.
>> I don't think there's enough cuz you'd
have to you'd have to recycle the one
purple to have one more dig, but then
you don't have anything to to to pay for
rebuke. There's no way really of
rebuking your way out of this called
shot. What answer is that? Is it
looking?
>> I mean, you can't pay for for punch
first.
>> I'm looking at what you can pay for with
four floating and one orange rune. Fight
or flight.
>> Oh, of course. And there it is off the
top of the deck.
>> Yes. And you're going to live this turn
with this. But then again, are you going
to win the game afterwards? You only
have one mind splitter on the field. You
are at one rune. Are you going to go up
to three runes? And your mind splitter
is not going to get any better. Also,
Lenzq is at seven, so he just needs to
hold with PEX. However, there is going
to be misfortune ganking, but 7Q is only
going to hold up to six. So, can go to
seven with a possible gank. Lensq, he is
thinking so hard about this situation.
Do you even have any more cards to play
with? What is the Ezreal going to do?
Oh, the Ezreal is going to be pushed
into the void gate possibly to reach
eight might in total with the Vex. Yeah,
because that then forces out that if
you're going to use the gank, you might
need to like challenge
first in order. But then we're we're
clutching at straws. We're clutching at
the tiniest of margins. I I'm at the
point where I'm like, I don't really
know what Sebie can do to come back in
this with Allen's board state. We talked
about the late game for Allen is
oppressive. Only
orange runes in order challenge picked
up from the top. Are you kidding? And
that's enough to just for this turn.
Just for this turn hold for now. But I
feel like Allan has tools to turn this
back around on on the following one.
>> The thing is you are at six. If you're
ganking now, you get rid of that unit.
Your mind spplitter is holding for the
victory point.
>> Exactly. But there's a mine spplitter on
the other side and a Fizz and it's not
enough for game one. Sebie is going to
concede. I think that's the problem is
you don't have enough utility to hold
that from Allen's mind spplitter.
Knowing there's two units there. You can
evenly take the trade and there's no
units left in the deck for Sebie.
>> What was that turn [laughter] from Alen
ZQ versus double volar imposing versus
triple mind spplitter eight runes open
with just a bunch of small spells, small
units. A raven bloom student going up to
12 might in total. Even getting fight or
flighted did not matter. He pushed
through it. Rebuke, rebuke, force his
opponent first to dramp himself, recycle
all of their runes so that these volar
imposing would be gone completely. And I
think in this moment, SebieQ might have
regretted using the counter spells, the
hard bargains
>> on the culture just to get a little bit
more tempo even though you were only at
three points. But, you know, I I I'm
sure you can uh you can feel this as
well, like the the read on the number of
spells that Allan has of like picking
exactly which one's a hard bargain is is
like you have to be so in it in the tank
to know everything that you need to play
around. So, do we think Mundo comes in
so you can contest with high might? Is
it rebuke to get rid of things like the
volley bears even more? Is it factory
recoil to bounce? cuz we know pickpocket
is not going to do the job against
>> well maybe
>> is it down well cuz of course yeah that
will uh be able to kind of deal with
everything. So you know we talked about
would Allen be able to play around this
uh Aurora deck seeing the sideboard now
I I kind of feel like there are more
tools in in the deck. We saw it in the
Ezreal mirror be very much about killing
the seals but there's a lot of ways to
deal with larger gear as well.
>> Exactly. I think that downwell is
actually a card that you do not want to
keep in your opening hand. I think
you're mulliganing it if you draw it and
if you find it with qual shots or stack
decks, you're also trying to put it as
fast under your deck as humanly possible
just because you are going to dig
through almost your entire deck anyways.
You are going to find so many cards in
the process and if the card is in hand
and your opponent might split it, it
might be gone. Yeah, downwell is a card
that we don't see too too much of yet,
but is the type of archetype of just
pushing everything back to hand that a
lot of players find frustrating uh to
have to play around. Uh just that
ability to just say no, start the game
basically over again. In some ways,
>> starting the game over again with all
your units in your hand for the Aurora
deck is a nightmare.
>> It's a nightmare. Yeah, because you you
only ever want them in in the deck.
>> Yeah. You will never play those vol. You
can play mindsplitters, but then you do
not have a follow-up for your mind
spplitters that you are playing out
there. They're just going to sit there
as seven might vanillaas. Both are
players. They are shuffling up their
deck. That was a quick and easy side
deck.
>> I would assume that these players know
their siding peds by now.
>> It wouldn't surprise me if these two
players have played uh versions of the
deck when they were coming into this
tournament. So, we can see Sabik's um
>> Seabik's sideboard as well. We talked
about invert timelines early on that
discarding
>> lots of cards out of Allen's hand is one
possible way forward.
>> I can even see another gust coming in
just that when you think that your
opponent might be able to push for the
next turn, you gust that Raven Bloom
Student preemptively. So you either
force out some interruption that is
already gaining might for the Raven
Bloom Student. So you dodge the Gust,
but then you got basically two might out
of the next turn.
>> Sure. or you just postpone the turn with
just one energy cost.
>> I think that's such a
powerful play to make work if if you
have the foresight after
>> eight rounds yesterday of Swiss, five
rounds of Swiss today, a grueling uh set
of matches today through our top eight.
If you have the foresight to to to
clutch the preemptive Raven Bloom
student, you deserve at least one hand
on the trophy. at this point because
that is uh the kind of plays that you
can only dream of making if uh if if
they pay off like that. It's an aspirin
climb game so we're going to going to
slow this down and sigil of the storm is
going to slow it even more. I want to
say one thing and that is we have been
talking about Alanzq aura farming for
the entirety of the tournament. Right.
>> I see where you're going. In the last
game, SebieQ was emoting heavily on him
when they had the mobilize and the
catalyst of eons and then the dazzling
Aurora was having to play it. Mobilize.
He is hyping it up again. He's blowing
the horn that gets him [laughter]
another rune, but it wasn't enough in
the last game. Alan ZQ was just too
good.
>> I thought you were going to say that
Alen ZQ was aura farming and he's about
to take down Aurora on the way. Aurora
Aurora farming in the way out of this
one. There's Ezreal just uh will
>> play it early. There's an Arcane Shift
in hand. Put that we know we'll get it
back.
>> I love discarding Arcane Shift. This
makes Fizz so much better.
>> And you draw a Fizz and you drew the
Watcher.
>> Yeah.
>> So the only thing that you're kind of
regretting with the Watcher being in
hand. I guess one problem with that is
if your opponent does manage to find the
catalyst that is a stack deck. If there
is a catalyst within the hand or these
cards, then you're in a little bit of
trouble because it's Aurora next turn.
And we know the likelihood. The numbers
are three chances at a mine spplitter to
ditch that thousand tailed Watcher if
you are. Ooh, okay.
>> Wait a second.
>> Hang on.
>> That is an interesting hand to look at
because of course invert timelines is
great to also find your own dazzling
aurora, but there is not yet one in
hand. So we do not see the seabq of
mobilize into catalyst of into aurora.
>> So does that mean that you have to play
the mind on the curve that you're on
there? Or is it you stack deck which is
what um Sebie has taken? Do you stack
deck and just go I'm going to draw. I'm
going to draw. I'm going to draw. I'm
going to look for the Aurora. Please
show me the Aurora.
>> I think that might actually be an angle
for an invert timelines. Now we know
that Alen's EQ has already drawn so many
cards there. I think this is another
moment where you can try to find a
dazzling Aurora. You put the Volibar
imposing to the bottom of the deck. What
would be nice is actually to discard a
mind spplitter because then you can play
a little bit with your last rights. That
is an interesting line that is
definitely something uh to consider for
this.
Sebie's
with it as well on on the horn going
through.
>> I mean, he's just having fun here.
>> I mean, already has secured best of
misfortune in the grand final. Secured
>> qualification to the regional
championships later in the year, but
still has the opportunity to bounce back
[music] in this one to look to even up
the score to 1 to1. And I'm going to
add, when you're in the finals of the
regional qualifier here in Bologna and
you're playing an Aurora deck, you can
really just enjoy this finals, right?
You try to get some of the runes, you
find the Aurora, and then you let Fate
decide what happens with your deck. Now,
already in the Aspirin climb, a Raven
Bloom is played next to the Ezreal. So,
LNZQ is trying to prevent a possible
misfortune
that is pushing accelerated instead of
just putting it into the base. Possibly
losing the Ezreal from the misfortune
and then pushing the Raven Gloom Student
into the sigil, which you don't want to
do anyways. That is an on curve
mindsplitter. You're spot on with that.
And now there's plenty of cards to
choose from. Double Fizz. Of course,
it's a card that you like to take away,
but I think in this scenario, you would
rather prefer to go for the good old
thousand tailed Watch here just to add
to things some turns ahead. However, in
this Oh, we're taking away one of the
two Fizzes. Fizz identified as probably
one of the most flexible, one of the
best cards of the Ezreal strategy. I
would have seen an argument that could
be made for call shot.
>> Okay. To to stop drawing into more
options.
>> Yeah, because Alenszq is kind of unit
flooded at this point. Right.
>> Right. So, he needs to find utility that
goes around that.
>> But I mean, you're you're going to find
your utility. Taking away the Fizz,
keeping the thousand tilt watcher in
hand.
>> Yes. And we know that it is a one-off.
>> Yeah. So
if it goes to the trash,
cold shot comes through
>> just able to play off the uh the seal
that is never not going to be
satisfying.
>> It's and something [laughter]
>> it's not as satisfying when it's the
turn where you played your seal because
you technically paid power cost for it.
But afterwards, every second time you
use your seal, that is going to feel
massive because you know how much value
you're generating, how much ramp you're
getting. actually is in the position to
get another one of those.
>> Yeah, I was going to say that's what it
looked like as uh we got a quick
glimpse.
>> Yeah, I mean we are finally
>> drawing cards is great. Drawing cards is
balanced. [laughter]
>> It's it's getting you where you want to
be. You're already setting up big turns.
However, keep in mind there was an
invert timelines in the hand of Savvy Q.
>> Yes,
>> very huge card. So, the thing is you're
not drawing too many cards. You're
exchanging cards one for one
>> as you say. Do you just do it now?
You've seen stack deck.
>> Yeah, this should be really tailored for
now.
>> If if your seb go like yes, please keep
drawing cards, please.
>> Another seal of discord is being played.
Where we go with this?
>> Is it the arcane shift or you just uh
Oh,
>> no. We take that back. We do. Oh, we
have the stack deck.
>> He's slow. Was it still? Oh, so we're
just stack deck didn't go to the trash.
We're just going to do it uh from play.
Was that the down well?
>> I think he found the down well. And will
the down well go down well because there
is going to be invert timelines. So many
mines so many different options.
>> But but but that in invert timelines as
well if you get rid of it at this point
like downwell this might be too early.
Surely Alan like again we talk about it.
We don't know that specifically they
practice, but um you got to you got to
kind of have it in the back of your
head. Okay, is that an actual option in
this matchup? Do I have to worry about
this? Is this the moment where Sebie
says, "Okay, we're not Aurora so much
this game. I'm just going to break your
hand."
And look, these aren't even cards that
that are that influential. You've got an
unyielding spirit. You're like, "Uh,
kind of frustrating to to get rid of."
Okay, at bullet time it's a little bit
frustrating to get rid of, but is the is
the the upside there? You're at eight
runes, right? So, you definitely want to
guarantee that you have the chance to
get into the dazzling Aurora at the end
of or at the next turn. So, what you can
do is invert timelines. You're going to
be at seven after paying the power cost,
of course, but you could also just hide
the fight of flight first, but if you're
doing that into invert timelines next
turn, you're not going to be able to
play dazzling aurora if you draw it.
>> That's very fast.
>> I mean, you might I don't know if you
have another mobilize, you might find
catalyst of aons. There's so many cards
that can get you those runes back. And
now Alan ZQ was like, "Oh,
>> bro, I just tailored [laughter] this
hand for for minutes. I've been working
so hard on this hand. Why are you taking
all of those cards away from me? I'm
losing two cards effectively. Plus, I
just get a randomized hand now. Yucks.
Look like at least a rebuke came off the
top. Uh Seb's just going to steal four
from the top. Doesn't doesn't even need
to look at them yet. It's like uh
there'll be something in here. Stack
deck to to refill. Hard bargain on the
back end as well. Maybe to even prot
prevent Allen from refilling the hand as
well
with the invert time. So, four energy
for the catalyst will be able to ramp
back up. So, hard bargain not an option
on the next turn, but I think the ramp
is more important at that point with a
stack deck as well. Will go for it.
Looking surely there's an Aurora now.
We've seen a lot of cards coming from
Sebie's deck. Oh, actually still does
not find one. That is absolutely crazy.
I was even going to say you might want
to not use this deck this turn. You're
going up to 10 runes next turn. It's
still going to be able to
>> be able to one plus Aurora
>> if your opponent mind split you now
after you have added one dazzling
Aurora. But that is not even the case.
You're down to so little cards in hand.
You're desperately fighting or fighting
for your life to find your win
condition, but sometimes it's just
avoiding you and we're low on points for
this moment in the game. So that is one
thing that that both players will be
taking into account. Allens are saying,
"Okay, I'm at two. I know my opponent's
only on one. Hasn't found the Auroras."
Unfortunately for me, my uh Danwell is
uh out of commission for this round. I'm
I'm trying to think if there's any way
to get it back. I guess potentially
last.
>> I was going to say, can you last rights
and then just like get through your deck
again?
>> Yeah, that's a tough long road to the
down. Well,
>> just developing a Vex on board. We have
seen what Vex does to big boards in the
last game and that is merely a
mindspplitter. But now is it time for
the top deck of the ages? Oh, it's
another invert timeline. Another invert
timelines. Oh, and a folly bear in hand.
Oh, a bit of invert timelines. So,
suddenly you're not so not so sad about
having the volley bear in hand because
we know we'll be able to come back. Is
this a misfortune from the chosen
champion zone potentially as an option
of what to do uh at this stage? looking
at knowing what's in hand. Um
trying to just keep some tempo on the
game, trying to just make sure that you
are progressing your game plan as you
go. And yes, it is as Sebie will think
about it for a second. Hasn't been paid
for. So, we're not yet at resolution of
that.
>> No, we're we're keeping this card in the
champion slam for a second. Yeah. I
mean, there is how many things is there
to do with invert timelines on the other
cards that you have in your hand? You
can just press it again, but at this
point, you're just giving Alen's EQ
cards if you use this card. However, you
also need to find your win condition.
You don't want to find any more ramp. At
some point, there have to be some of
those win conditions. I think even if
you're dramping again next turn, you're
going to be a dazzling Aurora time. You
wouldn't lose a last rights. You don't
have that one in hand. You're only
losing fight or flight and hard bargain.
Those are valuable cards, yes, but you
need to get Kraken.
You do four runes up. So, Sebie does
have options. Heart bargain and a
fighter flight from hand. We know
there's one hidden on the battlefield as
well alongside the mine spplitter. Um
Allan has stacked his units as if he's
equipping them to each other. [laughter]
Just creating one big unit. uh the the
Voltron effect. [laughter]
>> One big unit to conquer them all.
>> Yeah. Uh to be fair, you know, these
board states do get quite wide. And
Allan,
>> of all players, I think has played
extremely clean this entire tournament
and finds himself with one hand on the
trophy at this point. One win already in
this best of three. So, you know,
>> I'm going to give a massive amount of uh
benefit of the doubt to however you want
to stack your board
>> to a player of Allen's caliber.
Absolutely. I mean, you have double
rebuke in hand now. Honestly, if those
would get ripped by the invert time
lines. This might be massive for seq.
>> Gor point retreat. Get the fizz [music]
back.
>> All right. Now, do we have an out to the
mine spplitter already? I mean, we have
a Vex turn possibly. There can still be
fight or flight.
>> And the thing is a lot of cards got
discarded earlier. So, trying to recall
what was in the trash. There's obviously
arcade shift if you want to look at
taking back [music] eventually like a
fizz or something like that. And again,
keep in mind the Vex if it goes into
combat suddenly changes
>> the the game when it comes to the amount
of spells that Allan is going to be able
to play.
>> Fizz is being played and you're going to
get for a repeated call shot.
>> So Alan looking for more options to come
from the top of the deck. There's a mine
spplitter finds
>> andify. I think mines spplitter is huge.
Stupify is also incredibly strong. Mind
spplitter is going to try and play for
the future I want to say. So you're
trying to plan ahead with this card.
Stupify would be something that is going
to rack up that Raven Bloom student even
further beyond. Now double seals is
exhausted. You have used some of your
cards already this turn. You have scored
a point. Do you feel ready to combat the
mines spplitter this turn or do you say
we're in Aspirine's climb anyways? I'm
just going to let you hold here. I'm not
going to try and throw resources at this
mine spplitter that I do not necessarily
need to remove fast. Yeah, I don't ever
feel ready if I'm playing this de. I'm
like, can I just cast more spells? Can I
just can I just stay in the game? Okay,
Vex moves into the battlefield with the
students. So, we're into a combat
showdown. It is now time that everything
gets a whole lot cheaper for Allan.
There's the morbid return. It's going to
bring back the Fizz. We talked about
this coming into the finals. Playing a
card once means you're going to be able
to loop it about nine times with the
Fizz, with the retreats, the replay,
with the arcane shift, everything that
comes through. So, we know there's a
hard bargain in hand for Sebie. Those
are now expensive because there's extra
cost to pay because of Vex's
asymmetrical tax that it applies to
Sebby. Because we're in a combat
showdown, every single spell is going to
cost an additional energy and power
while this combat persists for Sebie.
And Allan will reduce his spells by one
power and one energy to a minimum of
course of one energy. But that doesn't
matter so much. Of course, Alan says,
"I'm just going to take this extra
little bit of rune advantage that I've
gotten from this tradeoff. You're only
playing hard bargain once. No
repetitions here." Goes down to one rune
open for himself on the side of Ellen
ZQ, but now there is going to be a fight
or flight.
>> You pay for it. Normally, you don't with
a hidden card, but when there's a Vex on
the battlefield in the combat showdown,
you do. And that is what's going to come
through. Now, Allan still within the
showdown. What does Allan have in hand
for one? It's a Rebuke.
>> Wow.
>> Rebuke is going to send this mine
splitter back. That is taking a lot of
tempo away from his opponent. However,
there is still a misfortune that is in
base now. You're completely exhausted
when it comes to your runes. The mind
spplitter is back in hand for Sebeek.
And you did not steal enough runes to
prevent a possible dazzling aurora that
could come from the top. And there it
is.
So Sebie, is this one of the outs to
find in this game? Importantly, all of
that for Allen was to get to four
points. Yeah, we're at still kind of
that mid to late game part of this this
round. There is the possibility to jump
up and of course we are going to nine
from Aspirants climb. So Allan is
shields down. A very rare moment where
this Ezreal deck has no answer to a
combaters that will get cleared out.
Aurora gets put down, played by Sebby,
and we're going to see what comes off
the top. We know uh we've seen a mine
spplitter go back to hand. I think we
may have seen one volleyball already in
hand. It's a mindspplitter. It was the
next card, so better to be the next card
than previously drawn. Do you take the
watcher this time? That is uh the next
question that Seavik will have to ask
himself. This is a card that can play
through.
>> I was like, I'm just I'm just going to
awaken everything. I'll just go A and
then I'll go B. I'll put my card here. I
channel I go.
>> Just make your make your decision. I'll
shortcut through my start of certain
procedure.
>> Oh, and the rocket barrage is being
removed from hand. I mean, that would be
an easy out to the dazzling Aurora.
>> Yeah, there goes some of the gear
disruption that we know that Allan has
access to. Downwell is gone. Rocket
barrage is gone.
>> Yep. Now Alen's EQ is at four. four can
be quite
far in the game if you're not playing
with Aspirin's climb.
>> Yeah. [laughter] Yeah. Aspirin's climb
makes it feel pretty far uh at this
point.
>> But the thing is Alan's Q has pushed
through some feels. Oh, the factory
recall is going to reset the dazzling
Aurora. Bounce it back to Han. Take it
away. It's already the first card down.
you know, it's going to be the one that
Allen selects because it was a lot of
pressure for now.
>> I mean, we'll leave it up to Allan here
again doing the due diligence, noting
down every card that's there, making
sure that the play is correct, but you
have to feel like spending the factory
recall to bounce to hand to mind
spplitter is the combination that
Allen's EQ would be looking for at this
point of the game. 100% even if it
wasn't even necessarily playable in the
next turn. I think I've counted six
runes on the side of his opponent. So
that Oh, wait.
>> But it's regardless it just takes one
away. It's like I don't want to deal
with that Aurora. Like get it out of
here. It is now in the trash. And SebieQ
feels the pressure rising for sure
because it has taken so long to reach
that first Aurora. That does however
mean the likelihood of seeing another
one is is relatively high because we
know we're getting to the dregs of the
deck now for Sebie when it comes to what
is left there. We've drawn through a lot
and Allen is going to say, "Okay, I'll
just score another point." And now Allan
is two turns away potentially with
conquering or scoring both battlefields.
Allen will be two turns away. It is
another Aurora off the top. Is there
enough to pay for it? 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
nine runes exactly in order to play the
next Aurora. Is that enough? Seb's
chatting with Alan. I wish we had table
audio sometimes [laughter] at this
point. In goes the Mindsplitter.
Mindsplitter will take away
the Fizz. Slams the Aurora for the
second time.
>> I mean, at this point, you're obviously
easily trading a Fizz for a point when
you're already so close. You know, there
is a lot more pressure coming. Another
card, his card.
>> So, before the Aurora starts resolving,
I believe Allan thought we were at the
end of the turn. So, Allan is skipping
to his start of turn procedure. Again,
it's been a long day and if we were
doing step by step, these players
probably wouldn't shortcut quite so
much. But they are in the finals. They
know what they are doing. We trust trust
them in this situation to go through.
Volibear off the top is going to stack
this battlefield. But game one, this
wasn't a problem for Allen. There is two
more cards left in the deck. This is
almost complete information about the
deck for Alen ZQ. He can just look at
this deck. can just see how many cards
are still in there. What might there be
in the hand of my opponent on the side
of Sevie Q? How many rebukes are in
there? How many fight off flights are in
there? But then again, there's also two
cards.
>> There's one rebuke. Huge.
>> If there's a fight or flight hint, you
can use that for the volley bear
imposing. No.
>> Yeah. And that's where the the hard
bargain afterwards because Allan knows
that's a fight or flight. Knows that
it's the one that is available.
the the hidden card to play out. So
Allan just shows it, says, "I've got it.
I already have that. Now, where do we go
from here? Where is the next
choice for units?" Alan thought about
potentially going into the battlefield
with the mind spplitter. We know that
Sebie has no ability to play anything.
It's a Fizz first.
>> He's completely exhausted. This is an
open field play for Allen ZQ this
>> and Arcane Shift. There's lots of
different things in the trash. A morbid
return as well would bring back another
Fizz.
>> This is just so incredibly strong.
Putting the morbid return onto the
bottom of the deck. Playing out Fizz
immediately, even paying one power cost.
You're so ramped up. Anyways, factory
recall again
>> just taking away the opportunity to play
for your opponent.
>> A card for the second target. We don't
see it very often. This time around it
is only six runes because you hit
another cut. So you cannot replay that
on the next turn. Alen ZQ is going so
straightforward to those next points.
>> And at this point, Alan ZQ, do you do
you trade the mind spplitter plus one
unit into the battlefield to to remove
seis as a cold shot? Just get all the
information first. What are your
options? Is it mindspplitter plus one
into one battlefield? take the other
battlefield with another remaining unit
knowing you have multiple copies of Fizz
potentially. Is there any access to the
watcher as well? I don't think so cuz
the morbid return has gone. So it would
rely on another arcane shift coming
through but a singularity will help as
well next turn if there's a way to
develop a board but I don't actually
think it's necessary from where Allen
is. That is not a lot of steam left in
hand. But how much could there be for
Sabi Q? He has full information about
the hand. He knows Ding or is not going
to come down next turn and also you are
threatening to win the game with the
next hold. You're going to push that
mind spplitter and the raven bloom
student against the mind splitter of Seb
knows. Okay, your two drop is going to
be an aspirin climb.
>> Ezreal goes to sigil of the storm.
Doesn't matter about recycling the rune
and Sebie knows.
>> Is there anything off the top that will
hold this? No units will really be able
to come in quickly. It looks like
Allen's EQ is closing in on the win
here. Sebie will channel 2 draw into it.
Looked like bullet time. Look at him. He
is leaning back. He knows what he has
done in this tough match up. Bullet time
[laughter] is going to be played. But
bullet time for a Raven Bloom student.
That is a trade that you will gladly
take on the side of LNZQ. Keep in mind
if he holds, he wins the game. If SEQ
doesn't conquer with a big unit, he is
just going to conquer himself. Exactly.
If Sebq doesn't take both battlefields,
which is basically impossible from this
situation, there are two copies of Fizz
on the back end in order to tidy this
game up and for Allen to take the win.
Sebie looking through what he has in
hand. It's an invert timelines most
likely just in order to just see what
Allan had, see how to close it out. Will
draw four cards from it. Going to show
the cards in hand. Lots of big units
from Sebie Q as he will draw the four.
How much is he going to be able to play?
Even the last rides wouldn't help. You
don't have units to play with. Seabq is
delaying the chance to win this
tournament for Alen ZQ. Is he going to
get through this? Kiss is conquering
>> the hand extended. [cheering] Alan ZQ,
best of Kaiser previously, best of
Ezreal here and now the best of
Bolognia.
Allen ZQ is the first Riftbound European
regional qualifier champion. And in what
manner, great sportsmanship from these
friends. They're hugging it out.
Everyone is cheering for Alen CQ. This
has been Ezreal masterass. This has been
Riftbound Master Class. He is showing
how great he is and he's cheering on his
friend Sevy Q and Alan ZQ. That was
truly a final of all time. sportsmanship
to the end as well. A well played,
hardfought final
and you can see how much it means with
the community here. They've come out in
force traveling from Poland to support
and play in the tournament, but to
support in the end two very very
successful players here at the regional
qualifiers. And wow, I mean, we came in
not necessarily knowing what to expect
outside of Draven, but Ezreal and
Misfortune to close out the day. And
Alan's EQ does it undefeated through the
run of the tournament. That is insane.
>> He's been saying that he is going to
destroy Bologna with his Ezreal
deckless, and he certainly did. This was
a magnificent run just just defeating
everyone. How perfect can a deck be? How
perfect can the execution of a deck this
complicated be? I have talked to
multiple players who have said, "Hey, I
have seen this deck before. I knew this
was around, but I did not try to play it
for this tournament because it was
simply too difficult for me to play. I
did not think I could perform with this
Azreelist, but Alan ZQ, a previous world
champion of Legends Run Terra, is now
our first European regional qualifier
champion in Europe. What a player. What
a performance. Uh, very clean as well in
the timed rounds. Very clean. Just
getting everything done, making sure,
keeping to time, getting through. Uh, in
the unttimed rounds, the decision-m
really on part. The Vex in order that
turn in game one where it was like,
okay, I have to get through two vols. I
have to get through three mind
spplitters. And I think that there's a
way to do it. That one combat showdown
where Vex just goes, okay, I can just
play a lot of spells, play them cheap,
play them out. and Allan just able to
remove some of the largest battlefields
that we've seen here this weekend and
just say no that's not a problem for
Ezreal. I'm just going to blink around
and do everything that I need to.
>> All of my units have two to three might.
I don't care. I'm just going to go
through this still. And there is another
thing that was a big hard bargain turn
on a cold shot that cost six energy to
Alan ZQ. And I was saying maybe this was
one of the pivotal turns. Even then, the
deck is built so brilliantly that with
the Vex, if your opponent hard bargains,
it's really, really hard for them to
even repeat it. So, you either buy
another turn, you get a lot of resources
out of your opponent because, you know,
the field is not going to expand, right?
There was already triple minds and
double volar. And I think that uh there
was no way if he plays it perfectly that
he's even losing that. I think this
Ezreal deck list, if you're playing it
correctly, it looked perfect. the level
of brain power needed to pilot it.
That's an issue.
>> It is it is an intense deck to play. I
want to take a moment. Of course, we'll
celebrate Alan's EQ some more throughout
the tail end of this broadcast. I do
want to note that Sevy playing a deck
that everyone counted out like if if you
spoke to anybody going into Spirit Forge
release, it was like, "Ah, Aurora is
kind of kind of dead. There wasn't any
tools. It's kind of out of here. We're
not we're not really expecting to see
it." Well, first regional qualifier here
in Europe. Uh and it makes the finals.
and not only makes the finals, we saw
some really impressive plays out of
Sebie in in the previous rounds that we
saw and hung in there with Allen. Like
really made Allen work for that game one
like that. It could very well have been
if Allan didn't find that perfect line
through that Sebie was really in control
from that point.
>> Definitely. I mean, he had so much
might. It was triple might split which
is already 21 might [laughter] and
double volar imposing which is also 26
might. That was 47 might over two
battlefields and Alenzq won in that turn
with a double Congo. What the heck?
>> Crazy crazy to get through that. That is
that is
>> bonkers. I mean we now look forward uh
in in some regards. I mean I know we
we've just finished our our finals, but
of course this is the first of multiple
regional qualifiers. I mean we look
forward to potentially uh seeing what
happens in Le. I think this is uh a mic
drop to the meta at least in Europe when
it comes to like
>> yes Draven is still good. Uh don't
>> don't panic Draven players Draven is
still pretty good but you know what's
even better Ezreal especially when it is
pilot piloted by Alan ZQ. Thank you very
much Leonard for all of your hard work
as as well as the rest of the broadcast
team. We're going to sign off from here.
Let's hear from Alan ZQ the winner here
in Bologna.
Welcome to the main stage here in
Bologna for the first ever European RQ
for Riftbound. I am joined by our very
special guest Dave Guskin, the Riftbound
game director. Can we get a big round of
applause?
[cheering and applause]
[cheering]
>> A huge cheer for Dave. Thank you
everybody. And of course it gives me the
greatest pleasure alongside Dave to
present our first champion of Bologna,
Alan Zq.
[screaming]
[cheering]
>> Maybe need some more encouragement.
Everyone I said Alan ZQ. [screaming]
[cheering]
ALAN ALAN
>> Alan
>> is here. How does it feel to be our
champion? I am so sorry.
You are our first champion here in
Europe. How does it feel to be on this
stage?
>> Absolutely amazing. I fa to do it at an
A, but I did it myself grand.
>> And that is the words of a champion, my
friend. Our first here in Europe. Give
it up one more time for Alan ZQ.
[cheering]
Thank you so much everyone for joining
us on this journey. We began this
adventure with 1,719
players and we are down to just one and
mighty is he. Thank you so very much
everyone for joining us. Whether you've
been in the venue with us or viewing
from home, we wish you the best of
travels. Good night and see you next
time.
Stars [music and singing] shining with
us. Your fire is contagious. I feel the
moon [music] on [singing] our skin. Love
glows out. Love strings in your eyes
shining through me. [music] Like the way
so that we can see.
Yeah. Feel the warmth [music] of my
love.
Shine
feel
dark.
When darkness [music] falls,
you are my light.
You take my hand
and hold [music] it tight.
You are my home.
I know it now.
Don't let me go.
We're safe and sound.
I see your beauty shine.
You radiate with light.
Our hearts dancing twine.
You're one of a kind.
[music] Shine
and feel my heart.
We're never lost.
Even when I'm gone,
[music] like cles
from near and far
above the flower bed
as we watch the stars. I'll never be
lost.
[music]
>> [music]
>> You are my home.
You feel my pain.
My soul [music] is yours.
Two souls the same.
With you I'm everything.
You never ask me to change [music] a
thing. They set our world on fire. But
our hearts will burn for miles. I see
your beauty shine.
You radiate with
our hearts dancing.
You're one of a kind.
Stars [music and singing] shining with
us. Your fire is conte [music]
love.
Love strings in your eyes shining
through me like the way so that we can
see.
Feel the warmth of my [music] love.
[snorts]
and feel
even when I'm gone.
I
don't
fall
above the [music] burn
as we watch the sun. We'll never be
sh
And I feel